grace ashley
currently leading the tournament more
importantly leading the grand chess tour
is wesley so with us
wesley this this was a quick draw on
your part uh usually players say well
you've got the white pieces you're going
to go for it explain to us your
rationale yeah it's my responsibility i
mean first i'd like to apologize to
people also organizers
also to the fans for the quick draw i
mean it's disappointing of course but
as a professional player
i kind of have to make decisions which i
think are correct and actually i'm not
thinking about the tour points or the
tournament standings and not one bit
it's just
uh i i'm not feeling very well today uh
i didn't sleep well last night i think
i've been drinking too much coffee
so i i got a i gotta minimize my coffee
intake and that so i wasn't feeling the
best spirits
and there's sometimes
richard is a very dangerous player he's
very strong uh he stopped almost in the
top in the world so there's always in
the back of my mind saying
just
be careful this game
um also
i've had history in the past before
where in the back of my mind i wanted to
play carefully
like for example against the pomniachi
two years ago in the sink world cup i
wanted to play carefully with white
and i wanted to make a draw at some
point but during the game i was
hesitating i got better position i
didn't know whether play for win
uh or play four though and then i lose i
lost that game so badly so i think as a
rule if you want to do something you
cannot you can't hesitate you just need
to do it so
yeah again like to apologize i it's not
my proudest moment but as a professional
i sometimes have to make decisions like
this and again i'm not thinking the tour
points
also against the berlin i think quite a
several ideas that could be playable for
a slight edge but then the game could
get long and if i made blenders things
could go bad
so it's again not my proudest moment but
i take full responsibility we understand
you don't feel well why all the coffee
what's up with that
yeah it's my favorite drink
i used to drink every day at home but
but yeah i this my third term in a row
so there's a lot nervous tension also in
in between games between rounds also i'm
i'm preparing and sometimes feel like
it's good to have a hot drink by my side
but i just need to lessen the caffeine a
little bit so because
yesterday i drank coffee at
nine in the evening and then i started
lying in bed for for the next 10 hours
and i could barely sleep wow that's a
big mistake but
again um
yeah obviously it's quite
it's uh not attractive to to go forward
with the white pieces but uh
i i play tons of games every year and
sometimes you
get some bad games but but i was also
happy to save the game yesterday against
fabiano that's also one of the reasons
why i took the took a quick throw today
because yesterday could have gone badly
if fabian played a bit better
let's talk about that that game i mean
it certainly certainly was a difficult
one uh when you you walked out of there
feeling feeling like this this was a
a good save
yeah i i think it was a very good save i
think uh i wasn't expecting fabian to
play 154
and i think he didn't get much out of
the opening but i also messed things up
and uh in fact yesterday was very nice
when he played a3
uh we bought miss after bishop takes a3
i just trusted him that he has knight b5
dropping my queen but then i miss this
a6 bishop a5 bishop b4 check id which
suddenly black is better uh anyway
fabiano is is a great practical player
so he's number two in the world i think
yesterday
i was doing very
very well but then he always keep keep
finding this practical chances and
objectively i'm fine but practically
it's not so easy to defend and uh
uh i made some mistakes and i was quite
fortunate actually that he played b4 in
the end game if you played bishop e3 he
could have some real chances but i was
quite confident my chances of holding
this opposite color bishop end game
but fabian as i said this is very
practical so he just poses
problems
on his opponent's problems are not
supposed to be there
your thoughts about how
crazy this tournament has been in terms
of all the decisive games we just never
see this at the sing phil cup or usually
on the tour in big events
yeah yeah that's true uh not classical
anyway classic yeah that's true well
there are some clearly out of form
players here like swirks and peter
and everyone wants to get a point from
those guys
so i think
uh that's
that's one of the reasons for example if
you look at other tournaments like
norway chess if
like argentari had a lot of losses
last year also john big hammer had lost
previous year when you have one who's
clearly lower rated everyone tries to
get a point of them
but also two years ago the thinkful cup
was much stronger with average rating
2782
so
you want to play for win with white but
at the same time you don't want to
overextend
uh so then you're playing a fine balance
of uh of playing for a win at the same
time not making a blunder
uh
and
yeah i must say peter spidler is clearly
out of form
uh and also we have some fighting
players like sam shankland and jeffrey
shaun
would you would you say that
somehow
the the tour should try to include
players of like diverse levels so that
we can see this kind of fighting chess
and you guys will be able to go for it
more or do you want to stick with the
old formula of elite players all the
time
uh personally i like elite elite players
because their
ratings are there for a reason i think
if you invite the top 10 players in the
world i think that's what gives
the most excitement maybe change the
format a little bit maybe don't blame
players but basically the format
uh
because for instance stay more rajib
makes draws but his rating is very high
he won't be in the top 12 in the world
if he's not a good player so i think
granchester has tried inviting new
players like like bador jabava or ivan
sarik
in the past but they haven't really been
able to compete for the top prizes so i
think
reading is going to defend my boy sarge
there he he got second in the tournament
very recently it was this
worst half that kind of room
you're right i forgot about that
combination
yeah i have to thank gary for for that
yeah you become second and then you end
up
that's right
gary had a poor tournament yeah that's
through yeah if i'm afraid i think
ratings are there for
for for a reason you said change the
format what format would you suggest
that could make for more contentious
chess because when you say excitement
the fans like to see wins they want yeah
they'd like to see decisive games and
and this tournament has 12 decisive
games two years ago 12 sizes games in
four rounds two years ago it was 12
decisive games in the entire tournament
11 rounds exactly yeah maybe
yeah chess is
is very
objectively drawn these days engine
always keeps point zero maybe change
format like gives slightly more points
for the wins or or you have another you
make the time control shorter and then
if players draw then they have to play
again in in a shorter time control i
think that's
that's what's necessary you would feel
okay with that oh i'd love to yeah i
played in play norway armageddon i also
like rapping blitz
i i think
i i love the farm still quite young so i
i can
adjust and i can play faster faster
chess but there might be other
uh suggestions also but i think the
format may be easier okay we'll put your
suggestion in the ballot box yeah i'd
have or yeah or
yeah there are other extreme formats
like you can play certain openings or no
castling but that's a bit too extreme
but yeah okay well
uh good luck in the rest of your games
and stay away from so much coffee yeah
that's true now i was thinking now i get
two two rest days and i'm going to rest
and get some sleep and try to come back
and and play some fighting chess we got
a lot of exciting shits coming so look
forward to it two quick two quick
questions for you wesley the first is
that i really liked
the norway chess format when they
experimented with the armageddons i
enjoyed it as a chess fan tremendously
uh
again your your thoughts
if the uh syncfill cup or
the classical chess events of the grand
chess tour was to use that format would
you
find that
acceptable yeah i'm completely open to
it just because
i also don't like
these drawers and if you're going to
stick to this format you're with all the
best players they're inevitably going to
have love draws like london one year for
example right so i think uh even if you
don't make the game immediately
armageddon but you can just shorten the
time control so if you draw in a 90
minute game maybe you can move the 30
minutes and so on after move 40 then you
can play rapid
blitz yeah
with the same colors yeah or i think
that would
make much sense or maybe you can give
slightly more points to the wins like
two two and a half
and then one fourth draw or got it
because you had such an easy rest day
we're going to put you to
work as a commentator i know you love it
i just want to turn your attention
uh if you don't mind to the game of
fabiano and uh jeffrey because this is a
kind of a funny grunfeld
defense
position but with colors reversed
and i wanted to i wanted to ask you
uh
is is fabi
over extended himself he just played the
move a5 bishop g5 and i've never seen a5
before me me either
that's why i wanted to
i wanted to to
tease you
with a4 bishop e6 and as a grunfeld
defense player
what's your what what what are your
thoughts i think at first sight looks
like
black just losing a bun yeah like knight
fifty or three
knight c3 yeah maybe not knight three
three d4
and knight before the purpose here of
course is that this pawn
uh now that the pawn's on a4 already you
don't trap the bishop right yeah and
then place bishop e7 and bishop f6
but maybe this is fine for black so
maybe not knight c3
but maybe i can place after bishop e6 i
can't play c4 right they take c4
should i take this trade the queen the
queen's
bishop b7 right this looks nice for
white
doesn't it
but actually after c4 i think fabi will
play d4 yeah he for sure because he
wants to keep all the pieces and play
four wins so we'll play d4 well this is
the
three the the risk taking
that you talked about is white i mean
okay jeffrey's not the highest rated
player
but he's quite capable if you give him a
winning position he's gonna beat you
yeah definitely now jeffrey's very
dangerous i think everyone is capable
uh so that that's what i mean you you
have to take a fine line between taking
risks and playing solid because you
don't want to lose it white same time
i've never seen a5 before but as i said
fabi plays for win with both colors
right
so this could backfire but he just wants
to keep the game
going so that's why i played e4 today
because
then you you know exactly what your
opponent wants yeah right yeah um
but black was fine
with knight f6 sub a5 but
it's going to be a tough fight now yeah
uh wesley uh congratulations thus far on
your grand chest store results certainly
uh you're leading for a reason well done
and uh get your rest we'll see you on
the other side of the rest day there are
only four players
right
all right it's nice i mean uh magnus is
not here this year so
and also ding
[Laughter]
we're missing some crocodiles that's for
sure all right thank